next I'm very happy to introduce
Anthony's Griffin yano with dun &
bradstreet and especially to thank
everyone else from dun & bradstreet who
has joined us here this year and also
for their co-sponsorship for the the
data summit anthony and others have been
with us every year of the data summit
and you know they always bring such a
great expertise and humor and insight
into so many fields and it's it's just
wonderful to have them helping us to tie
everything together here Anthony himself
is the senior vice president and chief
data scientist at DNB he is an
internationally recognized data
scientist with over 35 years of
experience in multiple industries and
enterprise domains extensive background
in linguistics that anyone who's ever
heard him speak will know very well and
advanced algorithms and he's the primary
inventor on multiple patents worldwide
really he is pushing the boundaries of
what dun & bradstreet does and he's here
to talk a little bit more about that
today thank you very much I have to be
honest I think several people have said
this when you when you talk to this
group there's no smartest person in the
room there's no expert of all experts
because everybody here has their domain
and if you are experiencing this the way
I am you sit there and every single
person that talks is in a totally
different direction talking about all of
these things that you forgot to think
about or that hopefully by the end of
their talk you're glad somebody else is
thinking about and so as I thought about
what I might talk about this year I
thought what a great topic to talk about
the things we forget to think about so
as we it's sort of like a coffee table
book about coffee tables you know from
Seinfeld as we talked about having all
of this data and we talk about all of
the things that we can do with the data
and we talk about all of the magic and
all over the possibility there must be
something that we're forgetting along
the way there must be some sort of rocks
in the road that we're either stepping
over or stepping on in order to get to
the journey that we're on and sometimes
it's worth just paying attention to that
for a second and so what I've been doing
lately I've stephen wolfram mentioned
his talk which really deeply touched me
how much effort on his part goes toward
just talking to people that are not
going to be his customer they're not
going to be his his next business
relationship they're the people of
tomorrow they're the people that are
studying data science or they're in high
school they don't know what they're
going to study and I do a lot of that as
well and one of the things that I try to
do is to be very reflective about how do
you use that time what are some of the
messages that you want to get across one
of the things that I see happening more
and more now is the tools have become so
facile that it's easy to just sort of
think well it's out there it's on the
Internet I'll just go get the answer or
I'll just take this din and I'll put it
in the toilet i'll create this cool
visualization and I'll go give it to
them and all of those things might be
true let me wave my arms in the air and
say machine learning and if I say it
with enough you know tenacity or deep
learning or you know insert new
methodology here everyone will think
that I'm really smart and I've got all
this figured out and sometimes you have
to stop and question whether you're
asking the right question the previous
immediately previous presentation did an
awesome job of talking about mixed
methodologies and talking about how we
use different methods to go out and
heuristic alee understand what people
are doing or what they're not doing the
questions afterwards and the treatment
of those questions in the in the true
spirit of say what you think out loud
and let other people challenge it
absolutely awesome that's what we need
to do and that's what we need to teach
I'm going to talk a little bit about
that so before I do I like to frame
things with a video you may or may not
have seen this commercial if you have
act surprised for your neighbors but
when you watch this commercial from the
fine folks at Adobe I have some sort of
formulating questions over here how's
the data landscape changing what are we
doing in data science to respond to that
and sort of you know kind of skills does
it imply that we need so are we doing
enough or are we just sort of letting
everything happen for us so while you
watch this think about the data it's
very short
Peter come take a look at this who this
the numbers they keep getting bigger and
bigger clicks her off the charts yeah
Yoshi it's Walter we're back
think it was it
please take a look at what Pope
everything you got right now
he really loves that thing
raise your hand if your company has done
something dangerously close to that at
least once so what are the big questions
this world that we live in that's just
filled with questions about you know the
v's a big data velocity variety of
arrest we're not allowed to talk about
that anymore well then maybe we should
talk about data sovereignty maybe we
should talk about what happens when data
goes into the cloud well we're not
supposed to talk about that anymore well
what about intent what about synthesis
what about the implications of what
we're doing well maybe we should talk
about that and then the way I feel in my
world all of a sudden all these random
words you know chronic alized and pink
and pancreas Impala grounded and bigger
fly they just come in i'm like i don't
know what to do with those I didn't even
know what to do with the words before
right so this is my world right my world
is not stable my world is not sane my
world is not something easily
predictable and yet a lot of the people
in my world are using regressive methods
and longitudinal data and well what
there's a disconnect there there's
something not quite right about that so
this is the timeline that's on the table
outside this is the awesome amazing
timeline that's on the table outside I
am I'm blessed I remember contributing
to this i remember that when the
prototype of this was out on the table
and people were putting sticky notes on
it and so i put some malfeasance sticky
notes on it but there were like you know
like when Al Gore in turn invented the
internet I put that on there they didn't
hit it to the timeline but so you know
this was curated from a bunch of people
that know stuff about data and pretty
pretty cool right but it's not me it's
not my life in data so I reflected on my
life and data right dragnet you know in
the 1960s right you had these card files
that they would use they would go into
the room and they would put things into
a card reader and then a bunch of things
would happen and cards would get spit
out and that was reality my father
worked in a police he was a detective
and he brought me to that room and that
was real and then you had the
bat-computer right I'm everybody
remember the packing
and it would spit out a riddle you know
and that me would have to solve you know
when is a when is a nut not like a shell
and I always thought if the bat-computer
knew the answer why didn't it just tell
Batman like why did it have to be so
cryptic about it but you know that was
sort of a metaphor i think it was campy
but it was also like computers weren't
really telling us what we needed and
truth be told organizations were very
siloed you had to go to the records room
you had to go to the place where the
knowers of knowledge new stuff and there
was a lot of siloing there's a lot of
let's tell them what they need to know
the finance department and the legal
department and the product development
people and the engineers didn't really
share everything they thought they were
sharing what the other people needed to
know well maybe not right well T that's
kind of still true today to some extent
I'm really happy to see that in certain
fields maybe not so much but the reality
is in business overall very much still
the case and sort of in the middle of my
life in data so far anyway might be a
picture like this a bunch of people
sitting on the subway listening to
Walkman or something like that a radio
and reading a newspaper what is it
that's people sitting in the present
reading about things that happen to the
past in the past and listening to people
that aren't there alright i think i
understand that day old news that kind
of thing maybe our old news if you're
listening to the news on the radio today
that same picture looks like this and
other than being in color you might say
well they're just using devices to do
the same thing that we're doing over
here but somebody else might say well
hold on maybe he is talking to him about
her maybe she's on a conference call for
work maybe she's listening to a live
broadcast of something we don't really
know what's happening here in terms of
the creation and assimilation of
information the truth be told when we
look at the world we live in right now
we don't really understand the data
footprint we wave our arms and we talk
about the Internet of Things what is the
internet of things right now it's a
bunch of things on the internet it's
they're not really talking to each other
as much
they're talking to a server thats
collecting information I shudder to
think what's going to happen when they
start talking to each other from in
anger like for real is there a way for
them to authenticate and validate each
other is can my thing discover your
thing and figure out what it's supposed
to do and what it's not supposed to do
and what by what rights and what rights
do i interrogate you not so much we've
got that figured out in certain
industries to some extent a little bit
nowheres near where it needs to be last
time we did that was with Bluetooth that
problem took about ten years to fix
before all the stuff really got out
there you know how do we keep my headset
from discovering your phone I'm not
picking on you you're just sitting there
right how do we keep my headset from
discovering your well we'll put a
password in well we forgot about that
well it'll just retrofit away it's four
digits that's good enough okay what are
we gonna make the password well they
have to be able to remember it because
they're going to lose the little piece
of paper well you get 0000 that helped a
lot right so when I look at this journey
of what's happened with data over my
life and I think about what have I
forgotten to ask most of what I think
I've forgotten to ask has been around
the discovery and the synthesis not
around the curation we use that word
curation a lot in this room right I
think we've been pretty good at how do
we bring it in but now there's too much
of it to bring in and so we point to it
and then the question is how do we know
it's there to point to it not one single
person in this room is thinking about
how their shoes feel now you're all
thinking about how your shoes feel not
some of you are trying not to think
about how your shoes feel right your
brain can do that automatically maybe
neural networks can do that to some
extent but the actual reality of
discovering data at the event horizon of
the organization and figuring out on on
face value without bringing it in
because it might be illegal or
impractical what's the character and
quality of that data and what might it
due to the decisions I'm making I don't
think we're so good at that yet Neil
Armstrong when he went to the moon was
pretty busy there were five pictures
five pictures of Neil Armstrong taken on
the moon this is not one of them because
he doesn't have his helmet on
actually there were four pictures taken
at meal armstrong one of them was a
selfie he took a picture of buzz aldrin
and he was reflected in the visor so
there were four pictures taken a buzz of
Neil Armstrong on the moon she goes to
the bathroom and takes 37 selfies so our
behavior has changed dramatically while
we're not paying attention and I think
we're forgetting to think about what
we're doing with all this data with
great respect to all the people in this
room and the binding force that brings
us together which is about collecting
and curating all of this computable
knowledge what about the stuff we forgot
to think about so one example of this is
hello Barbie does anybody know about
this story you can keep me honest if you
do hello Barbie is are a real toy and
the idea is you have a Barbie doll and
it's kind of like it's got a serie esque
thing in the Barbie doll there's a cloud
app and there's a little microphone in
Barbie and there's a Wi-Fi chip in
Barbie and she connects to the to the
Wi-Fi in your house and then the kid can
talk to barbie and say hello Barbie did
you see the blended a blah movie yet and
bar because Barbie talks to all the
other kids oh yeah heard it was really
good came out last Friday or what do you
think about the weather this weekend
well I don't know it looks like it's
pretty sunny I can't wait to go to the
beach and you know all kinds of clever
things and if you ask barbie where
babies come from or something you're not
supposed to talk about Barbie has these
clever diversions right really cool
really really cool and the bad guys that
figured out how to turn on the
microphone thought it was really cool
too because the kids were leaving their
Barbie's in their parents home offices
and their parents weren't talking about
stuff like that and all of a sudden the
bad guys were shorting stock and robbing
houses and doing all kinds of evil stuff
because they forgot to think about the
unintended use of the curation and
synthesis of that data coming from hello
Barbie so that malfeasant behavior in
the Barbie cloud became a huge
distraction for a long time so can we
make some new mistakes
so these silos of information I would
submit are everywhere and sometimes we
create them on purpose because we're
trying to fortify the information
sometimes we create them by accident by
not sharing the ontology zor the
metadata or whatever sometimes we create
them because of the very nature of the
fact that we speak different languages
or we work in different countries or
we're working on different problems but
if we could at least start with the
recognition that they're there and not
act like everything can be gotten to and
brought together I think that would be
an interesting first step so one of the
ways that I talked about this with our
sort of budding data scientists I talk
about these three universes of data the
data you have in hand the data that's
discoverable you can go out and get it
you can buy it you can bring it in in
some way but it's going to take time in
all of these painful discussions about
whether you can and how much it would
cost and should you and then there's
going to be this data that exists that
we know exists but it's not going to be
accessible you're not going to be able
to get to it so a good example of that
might be the information on your
personal income tax return or any other
personal information you have you might
choose to share it with me but other
than that I can't just go out and
discover it and it might be I don't
think the exoplanet research people are
here this year they're awesome but it
might be just data that I presume is out
there because I've watched The X Files
but I can't get to it yet so it might be
just data that seems to make sense that
it must exist right and there's a
discipline that we all learned but we
might forget around dealing with
situations like this so you know the
first thing you do when you look at any
data against any question that you're
asking is you look at the size of the
data and if it's you know normally
distributed and a bunch of rules apply
we can use standard sample size
calculators and you know have a nice day
and if it's not we can look at things
like super saturation and changing
nature's of certain parameters in the
data and figure out whether we have
enough data to ask a question or whether
we have enough data to understand the
answer we can understand the bias in our
question that's awesome right but for
that data that we haven't brought in yet
so somebody comes to you and says can
you use this data to prove X
my answer is always I don't know what do
you mean you don't know well I don't
know because I haven't looked at ax yet
and this may or may not be the right
data so give me a minute let me let me
if I handed you a bunch of data and said
can you use this data to prove anything
your answer should be the only thing I
can right now use this data to prove is
that I have this data right from that
point on we have to have a conversation
and some of the things that we can do is
we can sort of triangulate so we talk
about fraud a lot malfeasance bad
behavior how do you know the universe of
bad actions so you know what percentage
of them you're capturing well you're not
going to know that but there's ways to
estimate what percentage of commercial
transactions might conclude some sort of
malfeasance there's ways to estimate the
size of the commercially interacting
universe and so we can triangulate on
what we think we ought to be able to see
by looking at multiple sources and then
we can look at what we do see an
estimate what percentage of that so
that's an example of that and for this
data that we're never going to get step
one is to stop crying about it and then
step two is to use stuff we've already
learned like decision elasticity how
wrong do I have to be with the data i'm
looking at visa vie the data i'm not
looking at before the decision that i'm
making changes and there's a formal
science around that we all studied it
but truth be told we don't always use
that kind of thinking we just use the
data we have and we say well according
to the data i see do it all the time
i've read peer-reviewed academic papers
that all the time that say based on the
observations of the researchers and the
data studied the data suggest blah well
what about the dating it didn't look at
so we've got to be able to think about
what kind of bias is introduced by the
things we didn't look at and by the way
how those things might have changed had
we looked at them so too excuse me three
different scenarios and there's many
different scenarios but let's take the
one that we normally find ourselves in
where we have lots of data in hand
there's more data that we could go out
and get and there's even more data that
we're never going to get but relative
size we
like and when I say sighs here I mean
like predictive power and all that stuff
I don't mean actual physical number of
Records looks like we have enough data
have a nice day move on do something
cool in this scenario you better be able
to credibly defend the fact that the
data you used is sufficient to make a
decision so this dispositive threshold
is the point at which you have enough
data to make a decision it's not
necessarily the point at which you have
enough data to make a good decision and
there's a big danger in reaching that
this positive threshold and making a
decision because you can and not asking
the question whether you should so this
second scenario there's another name for
this second scenario it's called a
lawsuit and then in the third scenario
you know I have some data there's a
bunch of other data out here that I
don't have tried to get it couldn't get
it the law didn't let me I can't go to
Zimbabwe whatever it is I don't have
that data but I know that there's a lot
more out there and they know these even
more that I'm never going to get why
would I ever make a decision in a
situation like this I don't know maybe
if you want to land on the moon right
the first time they went to land on the
moon they didn't know what the surface
of the Moon was like it was one Russian
probe that had been crashed into the
moon and that was that all the data they
had them on the squishiness of the
surface they had these rules like if one
astronaut fell over because the surface
was too squishy the other one wasn't
allowed to reach it down and help him
they could hand him something to help
get up but they couldn't reach over and
try to happen because they were afraid
that both astronauts would be lying
there like turtles on their backs and
not be able to get up and you know it's
funny but it's also horrific right so
you know they had contingency planning
for that so sometimes what we do in
situations like this is we have lots of
contingency planning we have lots of
sensing in the system we have lots of
correcting algorithms we have algorithms
that can learn we do a lot of this at
Dun & Bradstreet so we're always looking
at things that we can't see but we put
systems in place to measure how the
character and call
the data are changing over time to
validate that the assumptions that we've
made our reasonable to reach the
conclusions that we have and we put lots
of those in places where we can't see
much here's a situation where they can't
see much right now and if anybody here
is involved in this analysis I apologize
in advance for my ignorance because all
I know is what I've read in the press
but this is the mh370 data that puts the
plane right now in one of seven arcs a
really pessimistic way of looking at
this is that 6 7th of that data is wrong
it's actually 6 7th of the conclusions
reached with the data so that's not
quite true but work with me and it could
be seven seventh of the data is wrong
the collective knowledge of mankind had
let has led us to the conclusion that we
have to look in seven different places
we're really smart we've got our best
people working on this and we're looking
in seven different places so the very
real human impact here is please don't
bring me more data bring me more common
sense somebody go back and look at the
assumptions I made and tell me where I
made a mistake somebody go back and
figure out what this positive threshold
I crossed by accident and drew one of
those arcs somebody go and find the
problem because without some progressive
decomposition here we're going to be
searching the earth forever until
somebody trips over it and by the way
what if the date has been manipulated so
another thing that we often forget when
we make the data so we talk a lot here
about going in getting interesting
collections of data sometimes we make
the data we measure things we have
transducers we have in our world we have
reporters that go out and collect data
we have agents we have an intelligence
engine that goes out and synthesizes
dyadic relationships we do all kinds of
things to make data we make a lot of our
data there's these things called
observer effects we all studied them in
physics I was in a second year physics
class one time I was at one point in my
life a physics major and one of the best
professors I've ever had I would
they probably the best did an experiment
with his class he asked us all he said
I'm not going to give you a lot of data
here I want you to accurately measure
the temperature of soup and the
parameters are you have to eat the soup
after you're done and you can't like
destroying anything basically so
everybody goes off and they start
studying different types of soup and
there's different you know thermal
characteristics he didn't say hot super
cold soupy their soup likes to that has
all different kinds of things in it and
then there's soup that's very
homogeneous like tomato soup and it
turns out you want something if you want
to accurately measure it you want
something fairly thick and fairly
homogeneous so everybody winds up with
either tomato soup or cream of something
we all come in and we all get something
like a calorimeter you know fancy
aluminum container with a hole in the
top that you put a some sort of a
thermocouple in and we all do more or
less the same experimental design and we
all fail because the minute you
introduce the temper the thermocouple or
the think of it as a thermometer the
minute you introduce the thermometer
into the soup you changed the
temperature of the soup and you're now
measuring this this temperature of the
soup thermometer system which is not
what you asked to do so eat your soup
and go construct another experiment lots
of times when we measure things we
change the things we're measuring or we
change our perception of where to look
or we change the machine learning
techniques because we think something
will be better there's lots of ways in
which we influence the thing we're
measuring by the fact that we're
measuring it and the things that we're
measuring in our case we look for bad
guys a lot well one of the problems of
looking for bad guys as as soon as the
good bad guys get observed being bad
guys or other bad guys behaving like
them get observed they change their
behavior if we model our measurements on
what we know to be bad behavior we will
measure what they were doing not what
they are doing whoops so we better think
about that when we construct systems and
processes and not just wave our arms in
the air and say data not that anybody
here is doing that
permissible use is the second thing so
the first thing was just all the stuff
we do to the data in these silos and the
second thing is all the stuff we might
be allowed to do or not allowed to do
and this is becoming increasingly big
I've heard several references to
permissible use over the last couple of
days if we only have this data or we're
trying to figure out how to share this
data and you know this isn't as easy as
just stealing your neighbors Wi-Fi which
I would never do the SSID on my mifi by
the way is called virus detected and I
have another one at home called weak
signal right so you know data is in in
the case of looking for these sorts of
things where we may or may not be
allowed to use the data the bad guys
don't worry about that right so we used
to look for things like bust outs and
identity theft and sir trade rings we
still look for those things and does
those things those things still happen
but now we've got cyber everything cyber
crime cyber security cyber terrorism
cyber you know there's a there's a
computable X there's also a cyber X
almost you know the cyber everything and
a lot of that stuff is people with way
too much time on their hands using any
data they can get to indiscriminately
without worrying about any of this and I
have to follow the law and have to
follow the letter and the spirit of the
law all over the world and there are
times where the law in one country says
you have to do it this way and the law
in another country says you have to do
it that way and I can't simultaneously
do both things because they're mutually
exclusive so one of the things that we
do is we talked to the regulators and we
help them understand the implications of
these laws beyond what they're
regulating to the economy in their
country or to the businesses in their
country or too small and medium
enterprises or whatever it is and in
your world it'll be some other version
of that the nouns will be different but
it's the same thing that we can't just
sort of react to the regulator's we
should never be in a conversation about
how do I get around the regulation it
should be what is the intent of the
regulation and how do i buy by the
spirit of it but at the same time how
about we help the regulators how about
we help the regulators regulate
they can get the intended outcome
without causing some unintended outcome
the legislative landscape today if you
were to look at all of the laws around
the world that govern the sharing of
data and the moving of data and we do we
look at this all the time these are the
big headlines data privacy cyber
security protection express consent data
localization this isn't a random word
cloud those are the top five types of
regulation around data today and data
sovereignty data transferring data
across borders the implications of
predictive analytics and complying to
standards and best practices those are
sort of the reactions to the law so the
things on the left if you were to hire a
room full of lawyers that know about
laws about data you'd be talking about
that stuff and the stuff on the right
I'm turning as i'm doing this little
tricky the stuff on the right is how you
would be changing your behavior one of
the things that I talked to the
regulator's about is this concept of the
dark room the idea is this if you took
all of the experts and all of the
information about a particular topic and
put them in a room and lock the doors to
that room all the information and all
the experts are in that one place that
would be the best place to go for
information on that subject but over
time the subject evolves outside the
room and the people in the room can only
learn about it through the imperfect
understanding of the people outside the
room over time that room becomes the
worst place to go for information about
that subject so what we have to be
careful about is creating these dark
rooms with legislation where we force
all the data into one place and we
marginalize that economy or that country
to the point where they are the worst
place to do business with maybe the
safest if we're worrying about
information leaking across borders but
not necessarily the best place to do
anything really really dangerous the
solution to a dark room problem is to
have a carefully controlled opening of
the window control whatever you want but
keep it under control and watch it
and allow certain things to happen and
then the conversations become around
things like what is public information
what really is open data and how much
data do we really want to be open do we
really want everything to be open
absolutely not really dangerous idea for
lots of reasons and when you talk to
most people including the people that
are really zealous about open data the
subtext is well everything should be
open except mike my stuff you know not
all with that right so you know be
careful data at rest versus data in
motion one of the worst things that we
can do to highly dynamic data is to
bring in a bless you is to bring it into
one spot and lock it down because now it
stops changing I have to tie was doing a
presentation in China one time they
don't say anything when you sneeze and
somebody sneezed and I said god bless
you and the guy said god bless you too
you know it's an odd moment so this is
cultural link so you know the things on
this on the right are the conversations
that we have only have these
conversations about these dark room
problems you know what are we going to
do how we're going to lock down the day
we'll just be careful let's make sure we
understand what you're trying to
accomplish finally part three is problem
formulation there's many different
versions of this cartoon with the car
going off the edge of the cliff and the
GPS saying recalculating right we've
probably all seen it I submit to you
that they don't have a data problem they
have a gravity problem right so what we
need to be thinking about in situations
where something breaks where we don't
understand is the way we ask a question
will absolutely inform the answer we go
find and asking the wrong question can
very much set you out on the wrong
journey and you could do a great job of
answering that question while the
environment is changing or while your
competitors are out there answering the
right question so the cost of getting
the question wrong is probably one of
the biggest costs of having too much
information and too many tools and
technologies to deal with it is you stop
you get lazy about the question you just
asked a sloppy question because if you
don't like the answer you go back and
ask another question well there's an
opportunity cost to that it took time it
took people it distracted people it
might have
in the wrong direction this is from our
internal values i love this statement
that we should be relentlessly curious
it's part of the longer message
embracing the change in the world around
us and really knowing that there's going
to be new problems to solve every day
and then my world looks something like
this right so within a very short span
of time I was told that my flight was
delayed 117 minutes 109 minutes 104
minutes there was actually a couple that
were 37 minutes one said it was coming
in early and you know I'm visioning the
plane slowing up at speeding you know
slowing down and speeding up and you
know and the reality is what I know
what's happening there's multiple
systems that are communicating to this
thing that's generating messages for me
and they're all trying to help me and
you know there I have a joke with people
at work I say I'm warning you I'll help
you right like you have to be very
careful when you try to help because if
there's too many things trying to help
they all they just create this kind of
chaos so we can be relentlessly curious
but we should probably be a little bit
more parsimonious about how we share
that curiosity so that we ask the right
questions I've talked to this group and
and many other groups about the sort of
nightmares that are in our world
unstructured data you know it's it's a
blessing and a curse right you look at
all these brands here and the first
thing you see is a jumble right and then
your brain starts to fix it can we write
algorithms that do that of course we can
but then can we draw appropriate second
and third-order observation like the
bigger ones probably paid more money to
advertise than the smaller ones or the
ones that they're all competitors
because they're all advertising in the
same space they're all customers of the
advertising company that produced as
sure we can companies that sort of let
you ship your company around and change
its name and change its content I don't
know what to do with that because we
look at the name and the address to
figure out what the company is right so
that's a really nasty problem language
we taught you know we talked about
language before this so many different
examples of how companies present
themselves in different languages these
are certainly things that in my world of
scientific observation these are some of
the things that I see
cause me to ask questions and then I
form hypotheses right so there's things
happening in the world of data that i
think are headwinds tailwinds it's sort
of neutral and some of the headwinds
might be things like well getting lots
of data globalization you know all kinds
of new business relationships that's
awesome for me right I can do all kinds
of things with that and this regulation
and this new types of malfeasance those
are probably i think i just said head
winds those are tell is those are
pushing me forward and depends on
whether you're landing or not by the way
whether a headwind is a good thing or
not but that was an airplane joke some
of these things are good some of these
things slow me down some of these things
will be either good or slowing me down
depending on how I behave so I get to
pick right and then there's the new the
postulates the things that I put on the
table that I suppose that I need to
teach myself and my team and the people
we hire we need to look for these skills
we need to be creating these skills in
order to deal with these hypotheses that
come from my observations and so there
are things like semantic disambiguation
and understanding permissible use and
data science and sentiment analysis and
all of those things so I I understand
sort of the toolbox within which I can
formulate my questions around the
observations that are making and that's
the discipline of this here's an example
you know costco we all know costco but
there's another really big costco in
another part of the world that's just
spelt slightly differently and that cost
go by the way is a chinese company with
a Chinese name that has an acronym made
up of English words I please shoot me
now right you know Bitcoin and and
FinTech and all the you know let's
anonymously let parties transact with
each other I don't think so I don't
think it's going to be that simple and I
don't think the governments of the world
are going to allow free commerce between
anonymous parties with no ability to
track what's going on inside so
something's got to happen there right
maybe you already know the answer here's
a helpful message I got from a text
messaging system I know it's about me
right but if you can't read chinese you
know so i could read this so i knew what
it was telling me but way the guy next
to me who was travelling on the same
flight got a similar message and he said
I know what does this mean am i under
arrest like I don't know what to do with
this so you know these are big problems
we use things like sound and meaning and
geo position and context and linguistic
inference and things like alternative
digital identities those are the tools
that we use to address problems like
that this is from some of the work that
we're doing right now so we're looking
at confounding characteristics of
language sarcasm neologism grammar
valuations punctuation an example would
be if i said something like well he has
a certain jinnah sake why am i speaking
English or French you know have a nice
day right so these are really big
problems when we're trying to look at an
article that says lift is said to hire
catalyst as ubers rival which of those
things are companies which is those
things are poorly spelled words which of
the things your brain is fixing it right
now I see several people smiling think
about trying to do entity extraction and
identity resolution on something like
that and and trying to get it even
remotely consistent then I love that the
man who created autocorrect has died and
they're asking him to restaurant in
peace this is from some of the work that
we did with Wolfram research awesome
awesome awesome stuff we continue to try
to leverage that kind of work for
understanding signals and understanding
the impact of new regulations
understanding what happens when
environmental things happen like
earthquakes and tidal waves we got to
keep pushing that edge we got to keep
using these tools to answer the right
questions to understand those
dispositive thresholds or all of these
things that i'm talking about tie
together and finally this is from a very
long story that i don't have time to
tell you but you know the ant pushing
the raindrop which is held together by
surface tension can't understand why it
suddenly formed in front of him and
couldn't possibly understand that he's
in a parking lot and he's trying to
influence his world right we're a little
bit like that sometimes
we can't possibly see the information we
would need to see to understand the
context of the situation we're in and
yet we're forced to make a decision so
we don't just throw our hands up and say
well it's impossible I can't do anything
we have to think about those new skills
and those new capabilities we have to
think about some of these things that we
forgot to think about in order to make
new mistakes tomorrow and I think that's
ultimately what it's all about I love
that that dr. Demming has now been
rebranded as a data scientist he can be
anything he wants he's pretty awesome I
do a great deming impersonation I'm not
going to do it right now but because
we're videotaping this but he said
without data you're just another person
with an opinion so everybody in this
room has more than an opinion and I'm
just trying to focus on some of this
stuff that we forgot to think about and
that's where I'm going to leave you
thank you